what causes a third eye to appear on dr
strange's forehead is it a useful tool
or a really bad sign keep watching for
what the comics can tell us about what
it all means warning spoilers for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
are ahead before the climactic final
battle and multiverse of madness
earth-616 steven becomes stranded in the
universe that's collapsing in on itself
a variant strange is isolated in a
sanctum tower with the darkhold a book
full of evil spells at first our strange
doesn't realize that this strange has
gone to the dark side he and christine
palmer initially planned to ask for help
defeating wanda maximoff but then
sinister strange grasped the darkhold
and a third eye appears on his forehead
things just got out of hand
616 stephen learns that the darkhold
corrupted his alternate self to the
point that he became obsessed with
finding a reality in which he ended up
with christine that reality doesn't
exist anywhere in the multiverse however
and sinister strange confesses that in
his failed quest he killed numerous
other strange variants they battle and
616 strange eventually wins out
after america chavez defeats scarlet
witch by showing her the futility of her
plan the film ends with strange calmly
attempting to cross an intersection only
to be suddenly forced to his knees by
what seems to be intense pain
a moment later a hideous third eye
manifests on his face the movie cuts to
the credits as strange screams and
horror the eye then briefly comes back
in a mid-credit scene in which clia a
powerful sorceress who has been
romantically entangled with doctor
strange in the comics makes her mcu
debut she tells him that an incursion is
destroying another universe and that
they must fix it the eye appears again
as clea opens a portal and guides
strange through it we don't know for
sure how much time has passed in between
the end of the movie and the mid-credit
stinger but clearly strange grew
accustomed to that third eye fairly
quickly when doctor strange faces the
illuminati they explained that accessing
the darkhold's power comes at a great
cost that's true even if the user has
good intentions as their strange did
when he used it to defeat thanos the
corrupted strange later reinforces this
idea since it appears on steven's face
only after he's used the darkhold
himself the third eye could very well be
the price he paid after all no one is
immune to the corrosive effects of the
darkhold's magic wanda too has clearly
been affected by the darkhold but she
doesn't have a third eye on her forehead
this might be because she was its
intended user or because she's a nexus
bean
did you know there's an entire chapter
devoted to you in the dark hole
that's the book of the damned or perhaps
the third eye popping up is something
specific to dr strange's use of the
darkhold considering his connection to
another key magical item along with the
effects of the dark hole the eye may be
related to the amulet strange wears
around his neck that magical relic is
called the eye of agamotto and it was
introduced in the first doctor strange
film
why is choice
you're wearing the eye of akamoto
once you've mastered its powers
it used to house the time stone which
gave strange the ability to manipulate
time and see various future
probabilities thanos destroyed the stone
but dr strange has refurbished the eye
of agamotto itself there's just no green
gem inside anymore but the amulet is
plenty powerful on its own in comics
it's named after agamotto one of the
members of the vishanti and the very
first sorcerer supreme it's wong not
strange who currently holds that title
in the mcu but important relics have
chosen a non-supreme strange before
based on his talent for mysticism and
his readiness to take on tough foes in
this instance his old magical item may
have imbued him with new powers after
his encounter with the darkhold a bodily
manifestation of the eye of agamotto
could mean doctor strange is ready to
take on even more dangerous adversaries
in the future along with the cloak of
levitation the eye of agamotto is one of
dr strange's most trusted accessories in
the comics and yes it sometimes produces
an actual third eye on the sorcerer's
forehead it was introduced in the same
issue with strange himself 1963 strange
tales number 110 the amulet's design is
loosely based on the all-seeing eye of
buddha a nepalese symbol in comics the
third eye isn't necessarily anything for
dr strange to be worried about it's
sometimes referred to as the eye of
truth and it often manifests more like a
blinding light than an actual eyeball in
fact in the comics it's not the heavy
toll the corrupted strange describes its
pure light wards off evil and lets
strange into the minds of others to read
their true intentions it can also break
illusions reveal disguises and even
control time and space
the eye of agamotto's usefulness and dr
strange's stature among the current
avengers indicates that the mcu could be
headed in some exciting directions after
the events of loki and that mid credit
stinger time traveling and portal
jumping abilities could certainly be
valuable but what might really be handy
are the eye's powers of clarity and
revelation the new secret invasion
series with nick fury and the
shape-shifting alien scrolls is in the
works at disney plus the all-seeing eye
would be a game changer for deducing the
identity of scrolls should they turn
against our heroes likewise a version of
kang the conqueror showed up in the
finale of loki and one will return in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania
older than look
this game is for
the young
given kang's prominence in the comics
it's exceedingly likely that we'll
continue to see him in movies and tv
series perhaps as the mcu's new big bad
kang can travel across timelines and the
multiverse change his appearance and
exist as multiple versions of himself at
once plus fans have been anticipating
that a kang focused take on the comics
secret war storyline will eventually
make its way to the big screen
if that third eye really is an
expression of the eye of agamotto it
could be the secret weapon our heroes
need to get them through to phase 5.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]